let's say a family wants to go to
amusement park that's a good thing and
activism Park does these
cinematic expressions their new art form
it's something different from films that
are shown normally in theaters open the
pod bay doors help I'm sorry Dave I'm
afraid I can't do that that's all thank
you to movie for sponsoring this video
Martin Scorsese's comment that Marvel
films aren't cinema is making waves
again with the release of his opinion
piece in The New York Times explaining
his position many cinephiles feel
validated and many people who are fans
of Marvel movies and other larger
franchises feel offended most of the
offense I think comes from a
misinterpretation of his statements as
derogatory but Scorsese gives Marvel
films a lot of credit I say again there
were all new art form he acknowledges
the talent that goes into creating them
and that his disinterest in them is
largely a matter of personal taste
he doesn't divide or insult anyone who
enjoys or makes these movies what he is
saying is that these big-budget
franchise films are different from the
kinds of films that made him fall in
love with movies or what he calls cinema
an art form that he played a role in
legitimizing and creating his concern is
not that Marvel movies exist it's not
that people like them it's that this new
type of film is crowding out the type of
film that he loves we don't really have
established terms to distinguish between
these two types of films so the way he's
chosen to label the difference is by
calling the side of film he loves cinema
and saying that franchise films aren't
cinema and a lot of people seem to be
offended by this I love long form TV I
think it's a powerful art form that is
often underrated compared to cinema
Scorsese also happens to say that I
thought for a while maybe long-form TV
as cinema it's not it simply isn't you
know it's it's a different viewing
experience you could look at three
episodes two four
but that doesn't offend me because he
isn't saying long form TV isn't valuable
he's just saying it's a different thing
you might disagree with him and think
that the cinema label isn't the right
way to make that distinction between
franchise films and the films Scorsese
loves but there is a difference one he
expresses in the New York Times piece
and one I can show you
[Music]
you're an orphan from a basket in the
middle of the desert and I told him for
no other reason that I needed a
sweet-faced to buy land did you get that
no no you know look at me you're lower
than a bastard
it's a book I deeply love but I'm
reading it slowly now so the words are
really far apart and the spaces between
the words are almost infinite
[Music]
they call as a Star Lake owners a stone
I don't see a lot of money here
Charlie carriers 45 degrees off the port
bow are you ready is your pistol cocked
mr. Linder yes again the point here is
not that one is better than the other
but that there is a distinction between
the two the core of this difference
rests in the themes that these two types
of films explore and the way they do it
Marvel films do explore emotional themes
but those are often the filler moments
between the climactic battles exciting
fights and character introductions and
what Scorsese calls
cinema these moments are the climactic
moments they are the ride that the movie
has to offer what happened in the end
and the end they shot him so it all went
to me
in Marvel films these brief explorations
of emotion are decoration for the ride
of exciting action showpieces if you
can't see the difference we'll have to
agree to disagree but I'd encourage you
to expand your film palette and maybe
explore more of what cinema has to offer
outside of franchise movies the Marvel
films do occasionally go to some
interesting places and I'm not denying
they hit some emotional beats very
effectively but in my opinion the entire
last decade of the MCU altogether has as
much revelation and emotional risk as
some individual movies from the last
decade but why does the difference
matter and why make the distinction at
all
well Martin's point ultimately is that
as this new thing as these theme park
films gain more and more popularity they
take up space in theaters there's a
finite amount of screens and show times
in theaters and the more space is taken
up by larger franchise experiences the
less room there is for the cinema that
Scorsese loves dearly great artistic
films aren't going to stop existing a
lot of quality cinema is still being
made but those films are increasingly
getting pushed on to online platforms
and the opportunities to see those kinds
of movies in a communal atmosphere at a
theater is diminishing many will have to
see Scorsese's latest film the Irishman
at home on Netflix instead of in
theaters because of the more limited
showings each year it becomes
increasingly difficult for me to see the
films I'm interested in seeing at my
local theater and every year those same
theaters are filled with more and more
reboots remakes at franchise films that
I'm personally not very excited about
one of the greatest living directors is
speaking up for a portion of his art
form that he loves that he sees as
disappearing he's giving a gentle and
nuanced criticism of an industry that is
creating huge corporate box-office hits
raking in billions of dollars and
dominating the theatrical market the
Marvel movies that people love are not
going to disappear or diminish in value
if Martin Scorsese says they're not sin
and the Disney Corporation does not need
you to defend them or their product from
a few rogue directors expressing their
opinion I guarantee you Marvel movies
and other franchise films are going to
be around for a long time to come
cinema or at least the kind of cinema
that captured the heart and mind of
Martin Scorsese might not be more and
more art films are having to move from
theaters to online venues and Mubi calm
is one of these venues Mubi is an
excellent resource that's helping to
sustain arts cinema online they have a
hand curated library of 30 films at a
time that's made up of international
films independent films films from
festivals hard-to-find gems and classics
you can stream them or download them
it's a great way not just to watch
movies but to discover something new to
watch and you can get it for 30 days for
free when you go to MU be calm / Thomas
flight
that's mu be calm / Thomas flight it's
available all around the world and if
you're interested in exploring cinema in
a deeper way I recommend you give Moby a
try thank you so much for watching
special thank you to my patreon
supporters you can go to
patreon.com/scishow
[Music]